so training with resistance bands has a
ton of unique advantages they're really
portable they're really light so you can
train with them anywhere they can be
perfect for rehabilitation and they're
very difficult to injure yourself with
you certainly can't drop them on your
foot and they can be used for all kinds
of alternative strategies whether it's
accommodating resistance we change the
amount of resistance throughout a range
of motion or whether it's joint
distractions where you open up a joint
so that you can improve mobility and
reduce pain and other difficulties
however the number one benefit of using
resistance bands as far as i'm concerned
is that it allows you to more closely
mimic a range of different functional
movements it lets you train more in line
with the principle of specificity and it
lets you alter the angle and plane of
resistance this is a huge deal i think
it's something that's massively
overlooked in a lot of people's training
and in the fitness industry at large so
i'm going to explain why it's such a big
deal right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so what do i mean when i talk about
angle of resistance well essentially the
angle of resistance is the direction
from which the resistance is coming from
so the simplest way to think about this
is that when you're lifting weights
usually the angle of resistance is
vertical it's straight down and that's
of course because it's gravity that's
providing that resistance when you lift
any kind of weight you're pulling it off
the ground and you can manipulate this a
little bit by lying underneath the
weight or by perhaps attaching it to a
cable or something but ultimately
gravity is what's providing that
resistance it's always going to be
straight down with a resistance band or
by attaching a cable you can alter that
angle and thereby place the resistance
behind you to the side of you you can
put it diagonally above you etc etc this
allows you to train in not only in the
sagittal plane but also in the frontal
plane of the transverse plane and this
is absolutely huge like i say it allows
you to adhere far more closely to the
principle of specificity so if you're
interested in functional training it's
probably because you want to get better
either at the things you do in your
day-to-day life or on a specific sport
and when it comes to a specific sport
then you're going to do things like
throwing a ball kicking a ball you might
be wrestling somebody in all these
scenarios you're actually exerting
strength forwards not up it's all in the
horizontal plane so having resistance
that's coming from down below is not
particularly useful and in regular life
you don't only exert strength by picking
things up you might be pushing furniture
you might be dragging something you
might be wrestling with a friend sure
you sometimes pick up your kid but even
if you do that you're probably going to
walk with them the best way to train
someone to swing a bat wouldn't be to
give them a heavier bat it would be to
provide resistance behind the bat so
they're swinging through
that resistance and at the same time
they're still using the exact same
trajectory and they're not pulling up
and down even something like a medicine
ball is a fantastic tool for so many
things but if you're just interested to
be able to throw further then that
weight is still the added weight is
still coming downwards and so you're not
really practicing the right kind of
thing and for all these reasons being
able to manipulate the angle of
resistance with bands with cables is
absolutely essential another big
advantage when it comes to training
specificity and trying to mimic a
specific movement is the option to add
different attachments to the resistance
bands in this case i've got a
grip that's supposed to be used for
pull-ups that strengthens your grip so
this is obviously much more difficult to
hold on to than something that is a
handle that wraps around your hand and
therefore i'm training my grip at the
same time as training my
core and my lats or my pecs whatever i'm
working
so if i wanted to become better at tug
of war because for some reason i keep
going on about that as an example then
pulling this is closer to pulling a rope
and of course i could just add a rope to
it and literally be practicing tug of
war should i do it slow motion
so here i'm going to be doing a single
arm band press and what's essentially
mimics is something like a bench press
it's a peck and shoulder and tricep
exercise where you're pushing forwards
against resistance the difference is
that when you perform a bench press
you're lying flat on your back what this
essentially does is it isolates the
chest it removes the role of the core in
stabilizing your body this is a really
good thing if you're interested in
building just massive pecs loads of
strength from the pecs and you want to
get a really big bench press however it
isn't that useful in terms of real world
transfer and of course the reason for
this is that whether you're helping a
friend move house and pushing furniture
whether you're wrestling somebody and
trying to push them over or trying to
push down a tree i don't know why
you don't have the luxury of lying flat
on your back and removing the roll of
the core in other words if you're not
training your core at the same time as
your chest then you're effectively
building your chest and not being able
to use it and jc santana showed me some
research that was conducted at his
institute of human performance where
they looked at the muscle activation of
the band press versus the chest press or
bench press and of course they're
completely different whereas one showed
massive activation in the pecs and
shoulders and triceps the other one
showed lesser activation there but also
much more activation in the core even
some in the legs and jc santana
explained this to me as trying to fire a
cannon from a canoe in other words if
you build the biggest pecks in the world
but you don't have the base and the core
to support them then essentially they're
useless to you so imagine you have 150
kilogram bench press you're going to
push someone over but all that's gonna
happen is your back's going to bend
backwards nobody can support 150
kilograms worth of force in that
direction or very few people can so
there's not a ton of practical benefit
to building that kind of strength of
course there are in other senses and i'm
not saying it's useless i love the bench
press but i'm saying that you should
also be doing this if you want to be
able to transfer as much of that
strength that you've developed to a real
world setting of course another
advantage of this version the single arm
band press is that you also have that
rotational element because not only do
you have to keep your core straight and
upright you're not only trying to
prevent it from extending but at the
same time you're also trying to prevent
it from twisting the other way as you
push you need to keep your core rigid or
even push through so you can also do a
single band press with rotation which is
even better now you could say couldn't i
develop my shoulder mobility and my core
stability independently of the bench
press could i do a bench press and then
do some one-armed push-ups and then
maybe do some anti-extension movements
and sure that would work to an extent
but when you train like this you're
using all those things together you're
not only training the right movement
patterns but you might even be training
the fascia because as we know the fascia
is responsible for force transmission
between distant muscle groups that often
are worked in unison being able to train
in the transverse plane with bands and
cables far more easily is another one of
the absolutely huge assets that this
type of training has because we do so
much in the transverse plane especially
in sports just being the rotational
plane anything that involves twisting
whether you're throwing a baseball or
any other kind of ball whether you're
swinging a bat whether you're throwing a
punch you can exert so much power this
way this taps into the serrape effect
which combines some of the biggest
muscles that go across either side of
your body your rhomboids your obliques
and allows you to twist and throw at the
same time thereby really getting your
weight and power behind a movement it's
why a baseball pitcher is able to throw
balls at you know 100 miles an hour it
seems insane that our body can generate
that kind of power but we need to be
moving in this way to do it and using
bands whether it's a wood chopper
movement or whether it's pulling it down
from overhead is a fantastic way to
actually train this and to learn to
exert that kind of power from your body
and the obvious movement that a cable or
band punch out mimics is the punch and
there you can once again
add resistance to a punching movement
which is so much better than punching
holding weights which adds resistance
going downwards the endless uses of
wristbands just wrap the band around
the band and then hold on to it that way
it don't cut into your hand anymore
and now with this lighter resistance
band it's far more well suited to
practicing cable punch-outs or band
punch-outs in this case pulling the
bands there like that with the optional
rotation once again mimics the way that
we use our bodies in real life if we're
doing a tug of war pulling open a heavy
door or pulling back our hand after a
punch and training like this
pulling your arm back against resistance
can help you to snap back those punches
faster which not only is important for
making the technique look crisp and
preventing your arm from getting trapped
or something it also helps you to throw
the other arm out faster this is one of
the cues that a lot of you guys have
given me to improve my own bag work is
bring your arm back faster and this
is a fantastic tool for doing that
exactly the same movement
added resistance and let's not forget
this one because what does this look
like
it's a choke hold of course there's a
situation where your strength endurance
can be a limiting factor that determines
the outcome of many a fight so you can
practice this as an isometric hold
the kind of position again that's very
difficult to mimic with weights and that
has a direct real world transfer
brilliant for building bicep strength
strength endurance
and mental toughness if you want to go
for a long period of time
this one's a great one for training hip
flexors and if you want to be able to
run faster by getting your legs up
quicker then this is a brilliant option
i always say if you're training and your
knees aren't a bit dirty you're probably
not doing it right
this is a great gentle one for the knee
so this is the flat power band style of
resistance band which
doesn't have the option of adding all
kinds of accessories to the end which i
do think is useful but at the same time
it does allow you to loop it over
yourself and it can reduce the friction
on your arm etc so has its uses as well
i recommend picking up both essentially
one thing this is really good for is
training in the frontal plane that means
moving side to side this is something
that again we just don't do because of
the tools we have largely i think one
great example of training in the frontal
plane with a flat resistance band is to
put it over either leg and then to move
sideways it's called a lateral band walk
because you're using a band and you're
walking laterally and this is going to
strengthen those hip abductors moving
the legs further apart thereby helping
to stabilize yourself with your
sprinting running picking up something
from the ground another big deal when it
comes to training with bands is the
ability to manipulate the strength curve
so the strength curve describes the way
that the difficulty changes throughout a
range of motion and this can be affected
by multiple things the angle of
resistance being one then there's
momentum when you launch yourself
through a movement then some of that
momentum is going to carry through
meaning you have to exert less force
further into the movement and then
there's the resistance the interference
provided by your own antagonist muscles
this is where compressive strength comes
in if you try and form a v-sit you'll
feel that it's hard because your own
body is getting in the way of performing
that movement the lever arm and the way
that changes so if you think about
performing a regular dumbbell curl then
as you curl the weight that's the most
difficult position because here the
lever arm is the longest the weight is
furthest from the joint so you're
effectively working against a greater
resistance then you have the elongation
of the muscle when the muscle is
completely stretched it's at its weakest
when it's completely compressed it's
also quite weak when it's right in the
middle that's where you have the most
strength usually because that's how we
use it so this is the nice thing about a
regular dumbbell curl because these two
aspects of the strength curve cancel
each other out where the weight is
heaviest your strongest and thereby this
is a fantastic tool this is harder to
accomplish with a resistance band
because the resistance band increases
its resistance as you get further as you
lengthen the band no ways to manipulate
this but that's why i'm not saying to
completely replace dumbbells and
barbells and kettlebells with bands i'm
saying to complement them with bands but
where bands then come into their own is
in allowing you to manipulate that
strength curve and plug those gaps to
strengthen yourself where your weakest
such as in those elongated positions
where you're at your end range strength
and this is really cool because it means
that now you can be powerful all the way
through that movement if you imagine
throwing a punch imagine not just
launching the punch and then losing
power as it travels but being able to
provide extra propulsion all the way
through an extra strength and that's
what you can do with the bands so you
saw me there performing a more
horizontal angled bicep curl where now
the greatest resistance is right at the
top in that compressed position where
the bicep is fully compressed because
now the resistance is coming from that
way it's trying to pull my bicep back
open this can be used to increase
mobility and by performing a weighted
stretch you can actually increase
hypertrophy because studies show that
adding resistance in a stretched
position can lead to a lot of muscle
growth and i can attest to this from
personal experience and from anecdotal
evidence so we can get into all kinds of
weighted stretch positions using the
bands which are going to help to improve
our mobility and increase hypertrophy so
don't think this doesn't apply to you if
you're a bodybuilder by the way the
ability of bands to change their
resistance like that is called linear
variable resistance
this is another big reason for farmer
strength and the kind of practical
strength that you see in dad's strength
and in physical laborers it's because
they're not just picking things off the
ground if you're thinking well i don't
have a random pole sticking out of the
ground and i don't want to go to the
field every time i train with bands how
can i train this at home then the answer
is you use something called a door
anchor you simply close the door so this
is on the other side and it can't slip
through then you can loop your band
through like that and you can do it at
the top of the door at the bottom of the
door and you can mimic pretty much
anything i've done here obviously you do
need a good amount of space in front of
the door so i admit it's not something
that everyone everyone is going to be
able to do at home but a lot of people
most people even if you're doing it in
your front door outside
so i hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around that
helps me out immensely i'd love to hear
your comments down below let me know
what your favorite exercises using a
resistance band or resistance bands you
like training to improve not just your
strength but your strength endurance
your mobility your resilience even your
brain function then you'll probably
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training there's a link
to that in description down below and
there's a discount on right now during
the pandemic i also have a print book
available from all good bookshops called
functional training and beyond that's an
introduction to the concepts of
functional training and how they apply
to your everyday life as well as to
sports and athletics you can also find
these clothes in the little carousel
under this video if you like them thank
you so much for all your support and
just for watching this one please
subscribe if you want to see more like
it and hit the bell button if you want
to be notified of future uploads and
i'll see you next time thanks a ton and
bye for now